I tried to talk about this over a week
ago and I just kept running out of time
but I think it fits in very well with
what we're talking about right now Anna
Kendrick the actress recently went on a
podcast to Lament The a breakup that she
just had with some guy that she was
really in love with but they never got
married and then they broke up and a
very sad Taylor's oldest time in
Hollywood but it got really really dark
when Anna Kendrick revealed that she and
this guy had actually
created embryos together that is they'd
conceived
babies
that they just locked away in a freezer
who now I suppose will remain in that
freezer forever
I was with someone and this was somebody
I lived with and for all intents and
purposes my husband yeah really we had
embryos together and we you know this
was my person and then about six years
in somewhere around there I remember
telling my brother when things had first
kind of gone down I'm living with a
stranger like I don't know what's
happening it wasn't just the oh I'm
losing a relationship it was that I
believed that if we broke up or you know
if he left basically it was a
confirmation that it's because I'm
impossible I'm lucky that he's even
tolerating my
okay so she's she's saying a lot of
things here that don't make sense she
said look this guy was for all intents
and purposes my husband
but he wasn't
and you were not for all intents and
purposes his wife
because you didn't have that ring and
you didn't take that vow before the
minister and the witnesses and the
public and God and because you didn't
have that marriage contract you weren't
you were his concubine you were maybe
you could have maybe even become his
common law wife if if you had lived
together longer
but you were you weren't cohabitation is
not for all intents and purposes the
same thing as marriage you're missing
the essential part of marriage which is
the vow to remain together and and then
you you went further down this route of
irresponsibility or you and this guy
went down further down this right of
your responsibility
and
techno dystopia
you
had children but you didn't quite have
children
and and the way that she says this is so
jarring it kind of sends a chill up your
back she goes yeah look I mean look we
live together you know we shared a
refrigerator
um we had the same Uber Eats account and
we had embryos you know and we had a dog
and we uh you know we we sh he sometimes
took the pillow in the middle of the
night and we um created human beings
together that we put in a freezer you
know and then we and sometimes we even
borrowed each other's cars say hold on
wait what did you just say
well I say we sometimes Bart each
other's cars no before that well you
know I no I I said that we uh we shared
the same refrigerator no after that what
was the thing of oh we had embryos
together you had embryos together oh you
had children
well not quite
not quite because now what you can do
because of our our technological
advances is
you can
make the most consequential decision
maybe of your life certainly one of them
to have children
you can
engage in the most significant act one
of the most significant acts you can
ever engage in
while still pretending that you haven't
made that decision while still
pretending that you haven't committed
that action while remaining as modern
people are so inclined to try to remain
totally uncommitted
because we know that whenever you make a
decision
to do something
all of a sudden
you are foreclosing the other options
available when you decide to marry one
person you are simultaneously deciding
not to marry this other person or that
other person or this and and I'm not
just saying this in a in a flippant way
uh well I'm picking this one gal that
means all the other gals in the world
are off too bad I would have had fun
with them no you're you're being a
little more specific
maybe you know you're dating this woman
but you
you still have an old flame for your old
high school sweetheart I don't know or
are you still you have a crush on that
girl from whatever and you and you still
you your ex-girlfriend you and you think
about her sometimes and and you are
deciding no that person dead to me that
person dead to me that other person dead
to me I will never
fulfill that love story that I wanted to
fulfill because I am making a decision
here and two roads diverged in a yellow
wood and sorry I could not
be one traveler and travel both long I
stood and looked down one as far as I
could to where it bent in the
undergrowth then took the other is just
as Fair
and having perhaps better claim because
it was grassy and wanted to wear though
as for that the passing there Lane them
equally about the same and each that
morning equally laying leaves no no
trodden black oh I kept the first for
another day but knowing how way leads on
to weigh I doubted that I should ever
come back and I shall say this with a
size somewhere ages and ages hence two
roads diverged and wouldn't I I took the
One Less Traveled by and that has made
all the difference
when in fact there's no evidence that
the other road was Less Traveled or the
other one was more traveled or anything
like that you're making a decision and
you know that way leads on to weighing
you're not going to come back to the
other one and people don't want to do
that anymore
that's why that's why younger people
don't tend to stay in one career they
tend to kind of switch up their jobs and
switch up their careers that's why young
people don't get married early these
days they well we just need to meet new
people and travel and have new
experiences and this is why young people
very often don't want to have children
these days is because when you have
children you are closing off a stage of
life that you were in adolescence and
you're entering into a new stage of life
and people don't want to do this this is
why young people these days I think
remain enamored of their childhood
interests
that's why you have so many more young
people these days continuing to pursue
the same kinds of activities that they
did when they were children I I said
look I'm not a big Disney guy but I
could see an argument for why adults can
go to Disney World but the reason that
adults should go to Disney World is to
take their children there I think it's
fine for adults to play little board
games and even video games and whatever
they can do all that stuff but at a
certain point
these things that are really for
children become
weird for adults to do
unless the adults are doing it with
their children you do you actually get
this opportunity to kind of relive your
childhood and engage in all these fun
things and roll around on the ground and
wrestle and play and do I don't know
throw a ball around but if you do it
just for yourself and you pretend that
you're still a child that's going to be
grotesque if you do it in the a natural
and orderly flow of life where you make
a decision go on enter into society have
kids play around do all the stuff that
people are supposed to do then it's nice
and it's nice and it makes sense and
it's good and you're not stuck in this
grotesquery where you just you're like a
hamster spinning on a wheel you're like
a hamster that was pumped with puberty
blockers spinning on a wheel and you you
don't go into maturity and then you end
up whining on podcasts about about how
you don't seem to be going anywhere the
rest of the show continues now I'm very
happy now that we're live totally live
again
to have the member block back you do not
want to miss it okay it's music Monday
baby we're listening to some cool fast
hip Tunes I don't even know what the
tune is yet I'll read the I'll read the
sheet The Producers left me
on the member block become a member
right now use code Knoll scanner WLS at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans we'll see you over there
[Music]